productive and efficient agri-food
systems
provide us with food that nourishes us
and livelihoods that support our
communities
nevertheless agri-food systems are not
performing as efficiently as they should
more than 3 billion people around the
world lack access to healthy diets
690 million suffer from hunger
while 2 billion consume low quality
diets leading to micro nutrient
deficiencies
and higher levels of obesity
the clovid 19 pandemic has caused
significant disruptions to food systems
already affected by other stressors such
as transboundary pests and diseases
natural disasters conflict and climate
change
transformation of agri-food systems can
help transition them to better deliver
safe affordable and healthy diets to the
world's
rapidly growing population at the same
time
improvements must contribute to
inclusive economic
and social development
[Music]
innovation is a central driving force
for transforming
agri-food systems digital technologies
are one example of innovation digital
agri food systems innovation
includes online platforms precision
agriculture
based on sensors geo data and artificial
intelligence
extension e-commerce and digital
technologies for rural finance
additional examples are blockchain and
food sensing technologies
delivering transparency traceability
food safety
and quality along the food value chains
most of these solutions are generated by
the private sector
currently adoption of these innovative
approaches by small and poor producers
is still significantly hampered by the
digital divide
public investments in rural connectivity
digital literacy
pharma registration in digital database
and adequate policy and incentive
frameworks
are needed to bridge the divide and
allow for more widespread global
adoption
of digital agriculture transformation
but it is not only about technology
innovation is all about solving complex
problems
and adding value in new ways farmers
herders foresters and fisher folks are
at the center of innovation
as custodians of natural resources they
have always
innovated to find new solutions to
complex issues
inclusive business models such as
contract farming
allow producers better access to markets
and a more stable income
adoption of geographic indicators labels
for food products
generate improved market position and
incomes
and recent online agriculture worker
platforms help meet supply and demands
during covid19 but all these innovations
must ensure access to
rural communities in developing
countries especially women and youth
women are key players throughout all
stages of agri-food systems
transformation
likewise youth are poised to make a
major contribution to this
transformation
by applying their education
entrepreneurial potential and
technological savviness to support
innovation
and shepherding adoption of innovative
solutions within their communities
public-private partnerships will be
crucial to help bridge investment gaps
in infrastructure
and access to facilitate small holders
participation
in the digital economy pilot public
private innovation projects
targeting developing countries farmers
are promising
ezoko digital and e-commerce platform
connects over 1 million farmers
in 10 african countries to essential
services
resulting in a 10 to 12 percent increase
in revenues for those farmers sms
services disseminating key market
information to farmers
in peru helped bolster prices for their
products by 13 to 14
the response measures to covet 19 can
also serve as important catalysts for
innovation
accelerating the transformation of food
systems towards more inclusiveness and
sustainability
and fostering employment opportunities
and access to healthy diets
for the world's most vulnerable
you